ا اهلا بكم فشل البرلمان العراقي في
اختيار مرشحين لرئاسه مجلس النواب ورئاسه
الحكومه ورئاسه البلاد ورفعت الجلسه
الثلاثاء بعد انسحاب كتلتي متحدون الاصلاح
والتحالف الكردستاني على ان تعقد جلسه
ثانيه في غضون اسبوع اذا تحقق التوافق
نتوقف مع هذا الخبر لنناقش في
محورين لماذا فشلت الاطراف السياسيه في
التوافق بشان مرشحي الرئاسات
الثلاث وما هي انعكاسات التطورات العسكريه
على مجرى التسويه السياسيه
المنشوده فشل سياسي جديد اذا جسدته جلسه
البرلمان العراقي جلسه كان يتوقع ان تبعث
برسائل طمانه للشعب العراقي لكنها عقدت
وفضت دون اختيار مرشح لرئاسه مجلس النواب
وهي الخطوه الممهده لاختيار رئيسي الحكومه
والجمهوريه حجر عثره في بدايه الطريق ام
اخفاق مبكر جدا ايا ما كان التوصيف الادق
لما حدث فان البرلمان العراقي المنتخب
حديثا لم يحقق المرجو من جلسته الاولى حضر
اكثر من نصف الاعضاء الجدد وراس الجلسه
اكبر النواب سنا لكن سريعا تجلت الخلافات
السياسيه في وضوح لم يقوى اي بروتوكول على
مداراته شهدت الجلسه التي غاب عنها نواب
الوطنيه بزعامه اياد علاوي مشاده كلاميه
بين نواب دوله القانون والكرد استاني لكن
ذلك لم يكن كل المشكله فما كاد المجلس
يلتئم حتى تق قرر رفع جلساته لاسبوع قابل
للتمديد لاسباب وصفت بالاضطرار
انها اشاره الى مقاطعه الواب العرب السنه
ونواب كتله التحالف
الكردستاني المرحله الثانيه من الجلسه بعد
فتره استراحه
للتشاور كان يفترض ان تسمي الكتل حينها
مرشحا لرئاسه مجلس النواب فيجري التصويت
عليه وذاك ما كان ليمهد الطريق لو تم
لاختيار رئيس للجمهوريه ومن ثم تسميه رئيس
الوزراء
الشاهد ان الكتل البرلمانيه مختلفه بشان
شاغل تلك المناصب جميعا وان كان منطق
المحاصصه قد تحكم فيما سبق في توزيعها
تسمع من العرب السنه اسماء تبدو مرشحه
لرئاسه مجلس النواب منها اسامه النجيفي
وسليم الجبوري لكن لا يبدو الامر محسوما
بعد وداخل التحالف الوطني الشيعي تتداول
اسماء لرئاسه الوزراء كعاد عبد المهدي
واحمد التلبي لكن نوري المالكي يبدو
المرشح الوحيد حتى الساعه ليس العرب السنه
والكرد وحدهم من يعارضون ولايه ثالثه
للمالك فزعي التيار الصدري مقتضى الصدر
نصحه بعدم الترشح كما دعى الكتل السياسيه
الى تجاوز الخلافات وتقديم مرشحيها
للرئاسات الثلاث لكن لا توافق ولا صفقات
في الافق والوقت يمضي انه تجل لماز سياسي
يتعمق ليست الحال الامنيه دون اثر عليه
فالدعاره تتعالى من داخل العراق وخارجه
تستعجل لملمه الشتات السياسي وتشكيل حكومه
قويه تتفرغ لمجابهه تمدد المسلحين في
الجغرافيا العراقيه حكومه تتدارك اخطاء
استراتيجيه المالك الامنيه وكذا اخطاه
السياسيه التي يذكر خصومه منها تهميش سنه
العراق واحتكار
الحكم معنا في هذه الحلقه من اربيل خالد
العلواني القيادي في كتله متحدون من بيروت
باسم ابوطبيخ الكاتب والمحلل السياسي
العراقي ومن عمان حيدر سعيد مستشار المركز
العراقي للدراسات الاستراتيجيه شكرا
لحضوركم جميعا نبدا من السيد خالد
العلواني لنرى تفسيره لفشل جلسه الثلاثاء
في التوافق على الرئاسات
الثلاث يبدو ان ضيفنا من اربيل لا يسمعنا
بشكل جيد اذا انقل السؤال الى السيد باسم
ابو طبيخ عما يراه من اسباب فشل
الثلاثاء بسم الله الرحمن الرحيم تحيه لكم
وللضيوف الكرام ولمشاهده قناتكم الموقره
المحترمين في الحقيقه ان التجاذب السياسي
الوضع الامني في العراق مما جعل المشهد
السياسي العراقي برمته وانعكاساته على قبه
البرلمان
ذلك بالضروره التي لم يستطع اعضاء مجلس
النواب الجدد تمرير ما يسمى بالسله
المتكامله عاده ما عودونا عليه في في
الاتفاقات او الاجتماعات السابقه لدى
البرلمان العراقي هناك امور كثيره حقيقه
لم يستطع تكوين النصاب فيها البرلمان
العراقي مثل
الموازنه فقط نست ذكر هنا الاتفاقيه
الامنيه التي صوت عليها باغلبيه ساحقه هي
اتفاقيه جدوله الانسحاب مع الاداره
الامريكيه اذا هنا الحقيقه اليوم هي جلسه
بروتوكولي صرح عنها رئيس جمهوريه العراق
بالنيابه باعتبار ان رئيس الجمهوريه هو
مريض في الوقت الحاضر وانتهت ولايته على
على على اقل تقدير لكن نقول هذه الجلسه
بعد
مصادقه المحكمه الاتحاديه على نتائج
الانتخابات واعتبار ه البرلمانيين
المنتخبين برلمانيين ان ذهابهم اليوم الى
قبه البرلمان حقيقه فقط هو
لاعتبارهم برلمانيين ويعتبرون من اليوم
فصاعدا يستحقون الراتب الشهري ويستحقون
المخصصات هذا النصاب الذي ظهر في الشاشه
امام الشعب العراقي وامام الاعلام حقيقه
هو فقط لتمرير المساله الجديده هنا نقول
هناك نواب موجودون في العمليه السياسيه
السابقه مثل رئيس البرلمان رئيس الجمهوريه
رئيس الوزراء هناك حقيقه تنافس سياسي مما
يجعل المشهد العراقي اكثر تعقيدا هناك
ايضا الاخوه
الكرون الى نقطه مهمه سيد ابو طبيخ الى ان
الجلسه هي بالاساس بروتوكوليا وان النواب
تمكنوا من تثبيت وضعهم القانوني واخذ
مستحقاتهم هنا نسال السيد خالد العلواني
عما اذا كان وهذا الانطباع موجود للاسف
عند كثير من العراقيين ان الانضباط كان في
الحضور لبدايه التمتع بالامتيازات وليس
لبدايه معالجه معضله
العراق بسم الله الرحيم شكرا لكم ول
الضيفين الكريمين اقول في البدء نحن نهنئ
جميع
نواب العراق الذين شاركوا هذا اليوم في
الدوره الانتخابيه
الثالثه للبرلمان العراقي ونعتبر حضورهم
وجزء من التحدي الذي يجابهون ه سواء على
المستوى السياسي او مستوى الجماهير وكنا
نتمنى ان تكون هذه الجلسه بدايه الانطلاقه
الحقيقيه للتغيير في العراق لكن هذا لم
يحصل لكن ليس هذا معناها
انتهاء الامور الى طريق مسدود اقول هذه
البدايه ولو تعثرت قليلا لكن هناك اراده
عند اغلب الكتل السياس سسيه وعند اغلب
النواب لتصحيح هذا المسار وللتغيير
الحقيقي في في عراق اليوم جرت العاده انه
في الجلسه الاولى بعد اداء اليمين
القانوني للنواب يتم الاتفاق على الرئاسات
الثلاث رئاسه البرلمان ورئاسه الجمهوريه
ثم رئاسه الوزراء هذا لم يحصل بسبب عدم
وجود توافقات سياسيه من جانبنا نحن في
كتله متحد والاصلاح ومن ثم
كتله اتحاد او تحالف القوى العراقيه نحن
من جانبنا هذا المنصب ليس ليس محل مشكله
بيننا
ومرشحه موجود وجاهز لكن يتاتى ذلك بعد ان
يقدم التحالف الكردستاني مرشحه ويقدم
تحديدا التحد الوطني مرشحه وهذا لم يحصل
وهذا مما دعانا في الانسحاب من هذه الجلسه
هذا اليوم نعم هو انت تشير الى ما يسمى
السله المتكامله التي اشار اليها السيد
ابو طبيق قبل قليل نسال حيدر سعيد عن عما
اذا كان هذا هو في الحقيقه سبب الفشل لان
التوافق السياسي يفترض ان يسبق هذه الجلسه
ويكون تتويجا لها وهذا ما لم يحصل وهو ما
يفسر فشل
الجلسه شكرا استاذ محمد احييك واحيي ضيفي
الكريمين يعني للاسف فعلا هناك احباط شعبي
عام مما جرى اليوم يعني ما جرى اليوم
يعني كان هناك احساس عام بان الطبقه
السياسيه الموجوده هي ليست بمستوى التحدي
المطروح ما حدث في ت حزيران كان زلزالا
بكل معنى الكلمه انا خليني اروح مباشره
الى سؤالك حول قصه السله او الصفقه
المتكامله انا اعتقد الطبقه السياسيه لا
تزال تناقش الامور بمنطق ما قبل ت حزيران
يعني وكان حريا بها ان تلجا الى وسائل
جديده لمواجهه التحديات المطروحه
هناك تحديات كبيره في العراق لا احد يقول
ان تشكيل الحكومه هو كل الحل لكن بالتاكيد
هو عتبه من عتبات
الحل غريب ما حصل اليوم يعني حتى الصديق
الاستاذ خالد العلواني الخطوه الاولى كما
هو معروف هو انتخاب رئيس لمجلس النواب
طبعا وما جرى اليوم كشفنا ثغرات في
الدستور الدستور لا يوضح اذا فشلت الجلسه
الاولى في اختيار رئيس لمجلس النواب ما هي
الخطوه اللاحقه بمعنى
انه واضح انه هذا المنصب سيكون لشخصيه
سنيه ومثل ما قال استاذ خالد يبد يبدو لي
هناك شبه اتفاق على شخصيه معينه لتولي
رئاسه مجلس النواب هذه هي الخطوه الاولى
لماذا ربطت باختيار رئيس مجلس الوزراء او
بتسميه رئيس الجمهوريه انا يبدو لي خليني
اتحدث بصراحه شديده تحديدا النخبه السيا
السياسيه السنيه هي واقعه تحت ضغط الشارع
المحافظات السنيه التي تعيش بكل تاكيد
ظرفا غير طبيعي ظرفا استثنائيا هناك
عمليات عسكريه وهناك يعني الروايه السنيه
الان تتحدث عن ثوره وانتفاضه وتتحدث عن
حركه لتصحيح مؤسسه الحكم يبدو لي فشل مجلس
النواب اليوم في اختيار على الاقل الخطوه
الاولى اختيار رئيس مجلس النواب هو بسبب
الارتباك التي الذي تعيشه النخبه
السياسيه لم تستطع ان تدرك المنطق الجديد
الذي
احدثته لنسال لنسال لنسال بعد اذنك لنسال
سيد خالد علواني حول هذه النقطه تحديدا
لماذا لم تبادروا بانتخاب رئيس مجلس
النواب وبالتالي تضعوا اللبنه الاولى
لاعاده لاعاده البنيان السياسي
المؤسساتي
للعراق
الحقيقه هذه كما هو جرت العاده ال اننا
نتفق على السله كامله للرئاسات الثلاث اما
ترك الموضوع الى حد منصب رئيس المجلس
النواب دون اختيار الرئاستين المتبقيتين
هذا الحقيقه نشعر به سيكون هناك ظلم وقد
يملى علينا اسما معينا وا قد يجري تسويق
اسما نحن لا نرغبه اولا او نرفضه وهناك
شبه اجماع داخل هذا داخل هذا التحالف برفض
السيد المالكي لرئاسه وزراء فجعلنا هذا
الامر كما هو اعتدنا في الدورتين
الماضيتين ان يتم الاتفاق على السله
الواحده قبل ان نباشر في اي خطوه تامه كنا
ننتظر التحاد الوطني ان يقدم مرشحه
والتحالف الكردستاني ايضا يقدم مرشحه
وتنتهي القصه اعتقد الشهرين الماضيين منذ
30/4 منذ الانتخابات الى هذا اليوم يوم
واحد يعني سبعه المفترض اكملنا كل ش شيء
وصار هناك اتفاق اما ارجو ان اكون صريحا
في موضوع بعض الامتيازات للنواب هذا من
حقهم نائب هناك بعض التداعيات الامنيه بعض
الظروف المحيطه به فاستحق يجب ان ياخذه
كاي نائب اخر ليس عيبا ان يكون له استحقاق
شخصي لكن العيب ان يترك العراق بهذا الوضع
المزري والاليين ثم لا تسمى الرئاسات ثم
لا يحسم التحالف الوطني مرشحه
على ذكر حس على ذكر حس على ذكر حسب المرشح
نعم على ذكر حسب المرشح هنا اسال سيد ابو
طبيخ عن موضوع شخصيه السيد نوري المالكي
واضح انه الان هو عقده المنشار كما تسمى
الا توجد امكانيه لتجاوز هذا الامر مما
يفتح افاق افضل بالنسبه للجلسه
المقبله الحقيقه انا اريد ان اوضح بعض
النقاط هناك حقيقه تشابك لدى ضيوفك الك
رام في العمليه السياسيه وفي هذه الجلسه
بالذات قبه البرلمان تجتمع وتصوت بثلثي
البرلمان في الجوله الاولى اما في الجوله
الثانيه لا تحتاج الى ثلثي البرلمان انما
تحتاج الى ننصف زائد واحد هذه سوف يكون في
الجلسه المقبله اما من ناحيه الرئاسات
الثلاثه والسله المتكامله هناك تداعيات
جديده كما اسلفنا هناك برنامج لدوله
القانون وهو الاغلبيه السياسيه التي وجهت
من قبل الفرقاء السياسيين بالرد و بالصدمه
حقيقه كل المفروض كل يتكلم حسب حجمه
البرلماني او حسب عدد مقاعده الاغلبيه
دائما في العمليه الديمقراطيه الاغلبيه من
تحكم وتعطي حقوق الاقليات هناك تشرم بعض
القوائم وكما عهدنا في في الانتخابات
السابقه وفي الجلسات السابقه ان من يستطيع
ان يشكل النصاب في قبه البرلمان هو من
ياتي بالرئاسه الثلاثه نقولها بصراحه قد
يكون هناك اتفاقات قبل الدخول الى قبه
البرلمان لكن هذه المناصب اصبحت محسومه
ضمن الاعراف والدساتير العراقيه ان يكون
رئيس الوزراء شيعي ان يكون رئيس الجمهوريه
من الاخوه الكرد ان يكون رئيس البرلمان من
العرب السنه هذه الجلسه من المفروض ان
كانت تنتخب رئيس البرلمان ونائبيه هذا لم
يتفق عليه لكن كما اسلفنا ان هذه الجلسه
فقط لتمشيه العمليه السياسيه وهي جلسه
بروتوكوليا لتث
النواب وباعتبارهم نواب منتخبين من قبل
الشعب العراقي ولكن المشكله المشكله الان
سيد ابو طبيخ المشكله ان الاوضاع العسكريه
الميدانيه ربما لا تتيح للطبقه السياسيه
ان تتحرك باريحيه هنا نريد ان نعرف بعد
الفاصل الى اي مدى الى اي مدى التطورات
العسكريه الجاريه حاليا في العراق ستؤثر
على التسويه السياسيه المنشوده داخل قبه
البرلمان لنا عوده بعد فاصل نرجو ان تبقوا
معنا
اهلا بكم من جديد مازلتم معنا في هذه
الحلقه التي نتناول فيها اخراق مجلس
النواب العراقي في التوافق على الرئاسات
الثلاث للبلاد سيد حيدر
سعيد الان هناك وضع ميداني
عسكري معين في العراق برايك ما تاثيره على
هذه التسويات السياسيه
المنشوده
يعني بالتاكيد هذا التاثير سيكون تاثيرا
كبيرا بلا شك يعني يعني
اولا يعني انا اعتقد وانا يعني كما قلت
بالجزء الاول ان اكثر من يشعر بالحرج هي
النخبه السياسيه السنيه الموجوده يعني
هناك انت تدري نسبه كبيره من الاطراف
السنيه دعت الى عدم المشاركه في هذه
الجلسه ما لم تكن هناك ما لم تن بني قبلا
رؤيه واضحه ل
تلبيه مطالب المجتمع السني في العراق فيما
يخص مؤسسه الحكم هذا الى الان لم تنبني
مثل هذه الرؤيه بالتالي بالتاكيد هذه
ستشكل ضغطا كبيرا الشيء الاخر وخاصه
التطورات اللي صارت بالايام الاخيره
وتحديدا قبل يومين قضيه اعلان الخلافه
الاسلاميه
وتسميه زعيم تنظيم الدوله الاسلاميه اميرا
للمؤمنين
انا اعتقد هذا سيفتح مسار الامور في
العراق الى مدى ابعد من الحدود العراقيه
الان قصه تشكيل الحكومه وبناء المؤسسات
السياسيه مجلس النواب وما الى ذلك انا
اعتقد الان الاطراف الاقليميه ستكون اكثر
فاكثر ذات سل به هذا الموضوع يبدو لي انه
الاطراف المعنيه الان هي اقرب الى فكره
بناء تفاهم اقليمي حول العراق هذا التفاهم
يعني قد تكون السعوديه الان هي اقرب الى
مثل هذه الفكره كذلك ايران وكذلك الولايات
المتحده وانا اعتقد مثل
هذا التفاهم يعني بحدود الدنيا في في
الاقل انا اعتقد راح يشكل سيشكل ضغطا على
الاطراف السياسيه العراقيه ل يعني المضي
بمسار تشكيل هذه المؤسسات
كعتبة استبدال شخصيات معينه تقديم شخصيات
معينه بما يشكل تسويه او ترتيبات يعني
تشكل حد ادنى من الثقه بين المكونات
العراقيه ولكن اسمح لي اسمح لي حتى في ظل
وجود اسمح لي حتى في ظل وجود هذا التفاهم
الاقليمي الواقع العسكري الميداني وهنا
اسال السيد خالد العلواني الواقع العسكري
الميداني يجعل من الصف السني كما اشار
ضيفنا في وضع مرتبك الى حد ما كيف يمكن ال
الفصل بين الجانب المطلبي المشروع للسنه
وبين من يوصفون بالتنظيمات الارهابيه وهذه
اعتقد نقطه جوهريه الان في
العراق يؤسفنا ان الاداء الحكومي السيء هو
من اوصى الامور لهذه النتيجه فضلا انه
اراد ان يصور كل اهل السنه وكل المحافظات
المنتفض انها داعش وانها ارهاب وانها
صدامي وانهم تكفرين هذا الامر مرفوض واصبح
يعني معيب الكلام حوله لكن للامانه نقول
ان نوابنا جاؤوا الى البرلمان اليوم ورجل
رجل يقدمونها واخرى يؤخرون وكيف ويرون
محافظاتهم قد انتهت وقد عاش فيها القتل
والدمار والخراب والتفجير والقصف وما الى
ذلك وحتى التحالف الوطني هو تناسى دعوه
المرجعيات الشيعيه لتسميه الرئاسات الثلاث
فاخوانكم على على من يحرص على العراق من
الكتل الاخرى سواء التحالف الكردستاني او
التحالف الوطني ان ينظر
بعين عين الحب والحرص على العراق العراق
كلنا ابنائه فترك ترك محافظاتنا بهذا
الشكل نحن لا نقبله اقول نوابنا جاؤوا
اليوم وقد سمعوا
اصوات المجمع الفقهي والحراك الشعبي وكلها
دعت الى ان تكون هناك خارطه طريق واضحه
لعمليه سياسيه جديده وكل هذا لم يحصل
وقبلنا الحضور في هذه الجلسه رغبه منا
في مسير الامور بشكل جيد وهذا الحقيقه
تعثر هذا اليوم نتمنى على الكتلتين
المتبقيتين وخاصه التحالف الوطني ان يسمي
مرشحه وان يكون مع المرشح برنامج وطني
حقيقي للتغيير وهذا ما دعت له كل القوى
سواء الداخليه او الخارجيه حتى من جاء
وزير
الخارجيه البريطاني او كيري الامريكي كلهم
دعوا الى التغيير والوجوه الجديده السيد
مقتدى الصدر دعا بهذه الدعوه اقول لماذا
يتاخر اخواننا خاصه في التح الوطني وترك
العراق في في هاويه سحيقه لا سامح الله
كلنا امل ان ينتهي كل نوابنا وكل
السياسيين وجمهورنا نعم كيف يمكن التقدم
في هذا الاتجاه هنا اسال
سيد ابو طبيخ كيف يمكن التقدم في هذا
الاتجاه وال الحكومه المركزيه والدوله
العراقيه تشعر لانها مهدده في وحدتها ومهد
في مستقبلها محافظات بالكامل خارج السيطره
واقليم كردستان العراق يتحدث مسعود
البرزاني عن امكانيه اجراء استفتاء لاعلان
الاستقلال هل من السهل الوصول الى
ذلك حقيقه هذا هو المشهد الهزيل الذي
نلاحظه منذ دخول الاحتلال الامريكي منذ
عام 2003 ولحد الان لحد الان الخطاب
السياسي حقيقه فقه السياسه ابجديات هذه
اللعبه حتى لدى البرلمانيين او الساسه
العراقيه لم يضعوا العراق امام عيون الحس
الوطني الشعور الوطني كل يتكلم طائفتي
مكوني
همشت انا اريد كذا اذا يذهبون الى
المحاصصه و يتناسون ان كل نائب انتخبه
اكثر من 100000 مواطن عراقي هم حقيقه
يطمحون ويصبون الى ان يكون العراق واحدا
قويا مؤثرا حتى في القرار الاستراتيجي لكن
هذه النظ
ضمن هذا المطق نفسه الذي تتحدث به الا
يفترض ان يكون السيد نوري المالكي اول من
يؤمن به لان واضح ان هناك شبه اجماع من
خارج دوله القانون على ان هذا الرجل لا
يمكن ان يكون رمزا لوحده البلد بكل ما
مثله من اخطاء على الاقل من وجهه نظر
معارضي الا يمكن ان يكون هناك ايضا فن فن
التنازل في هذا الموضوع نعم نعم دعني دعني
اكمل الفكره دعني اكمل الفكره اللعبه
البرلمانيه هي لعبه ارقام في الحقيقه
اللعبه البرلمانيه هي لعبه ارقام المالكي
جاء ب 95 مقعد اذا بينه وبين اقرب منافسيه
فرق 60 مقعد اذا هنا اللعبه لعبه ارقام
لكن الاخوه وجميع العراقيين انا اقولها
بصراحه ولا اريد ان اسمي مكونات لم
يتعودوا على العمل المعارض المعارضه في
البرلمان هي تعمل لتصحيح مسار الحكومه وت
تستطيع ان تسحب هذه الثقه من الحكومه
وتسقطها يوما اخر لكن لم يتعودوا هذه
اللغه كل يريد ان يحافظ على زعامات
وامبراطور ته ان كان من رئيس الوزراء ومن
رئيس الجمهوريه ومن ومن رئيس البرلمان
لماذا لا يتنازل الاخر لماذا لم المفروض
اليوم يعين رئيس البرلمان اخر من يتعين هو
رئيس الوزراء اذا لا يرمو الكره في ملعب
الائتلاف الوطني الحقيقه هناك حقيقه لعب
وتجاذب سياسي لانه بعضهم من يفقد مناصبه
ومخصصاته التي اكتسبها في اللعبه خف نضع
العراق التجاذب السياسي الذي تشير اليه
زوبه وهنا اس خالد العلان نهايه يزداد
صعوبه بهذا التطور العسكري الميداني عندما
تكون هناك عندما يكون هناك ضغط عسكري الا
يمكن ان يتحول الى ضغط سياسي على كل
الاطراف وعليكم تحديدا في تحديد مستقبل
العمليه السياسيه في
البلاد اكيد الواقع مداني في
محافظاتنا يضغط علينا بشكل ليس مقبول
الثمان سنوات الماضيه لدورتين انتخابيتين
جعلتنا
نفكر با اصلا بدخول عمليه السياسيه وبدانا
نفكر من من حيث عدم الجدوى من وجودنا لكن
وجودنا بالعمليه السياسيه نقول اننا نخفف
الضرر نخفف ضرر نشارك مع اخواننا من
الشيعه سواء اخواننا الكرد كلهم ابناء
العراق كل هذا الوضع لم يقبله الطرف في
الاخر بدا الاخرون لا يستجيبوا لنداءات
وصراخات وجمهور ينادي لسنه كامله من حراك
من مظالم من من قتل ودماء الى ان وصلت
الامور لهذا المستوى الامور اختلفت عن
السابق ما بعد عش حزيران الامور اصبحت
سيئه جدا فالمفترض الحريص على بلده ان
يتنازل عن كرسيه لاجل العراق كله شكرا
جزيلا لضيوفنا خالد العلواني من اربيل
باسم ابو طبيخ
من من بيروت
و حيدر سعيد كان معنا من عمان في امان
الله